[Music]
when i was a young man younger man my
first major talk show that i got to
appear on was david letterman never
forget it terrifying too but i told him
a story
about a thing that had just happened to
me i planned on telling the story and i
thought it would go by you know 30
seconds a minute my entire segment was
taken up telling it because i get
getting sidetracked kind of like i'm
doing now i haven't really learned i
guess but it was a story about a car of
mine that was being transported on a
flatbed truck and the truck got stuck on
train tracks in inman south carolina
and a train game came through and
demolished the the car and i was still
paying payments on the car do you
remember that car that old miata
anyway he was very nice to me and like
helped me along with the story kind of
like what you're not doing now yeah so
the point of this story is that you used
to be long-winded and
[Music]
you couldn't get stories out
yeah i guess so what's the lesson well
um
here's the lesson keep on keeping on
sure
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i'm
your host justin long life could be a
dream
[Music]
with me as always is my paul schaefer
christian what curse
um i guess i am paul schaefer yeah
you're kind of like he'd have a nice i
prefer andy richter me too i think but
see paul or edward mcmahon
oh do you
actually of those three i would rather
be compared to andy rick do you ever
watch uh oh ed mcmahon was is hilarious
remember i was introduced to him really
through phil hartman's impression on snl
which in fact yeah when i think about
mcmahon i think of that impression you
are correct
also i when i think of george h.w bush i
think more of david harvey's impression
you know both everything in dana carver
you think of georgia
because i was pretty young when he was
president so i don't have the clearest
memory a thousand points yeah knack and
dat yeah i picture that in fact we had
uh he must have been so annoyed by that
impression because it made him sound so
torpy i know but he was like a war hero
well yeah see we at that totally formed
my opinion of uh george h.w bush too
you're right he must have been
i don't i don't know if he's thinking
about he's definitely not thinking about
our perception of him who well george h
though he's not i think that's right
he's not alive right well um right but
we did have this you forget that yes i
did i did
we uh we had this debate the other day
you were like incredulous
that george h w
is the better looking bush president i'm
still incredulous yeah i don't think
there's a a debate so i thought george w
i thought w was the better looking and i
think the reason you think that is
because dana carvey's impression was so
torpedo
of him in your mind as like an
unattractive guy but if you look at old
pictures of george h.w you showed me the
stud you showed me from your wallet
nothing against george w bush but he's
you know he's more of an average looking
guy your point was that w was more
simian had a more simian quality
definitely yeah which um if you look at
older pictures he does but i think he
aged into a
anyway why are we talking about the
comparison of the bush presidencies uh
i'll tell you why we're talking about
that it's a vain thing to talk about and
our guest today is um does have some
vanity no sure but i think it was more
you're talking about letterman because
he is uh our guest today
was a talk show host of sorts yes and
not a talk show well no more host yeah
our guest today was hosted a show that
incorporated clips from talk shows like
the one i was on lo these many years ago
yes where i was rambling it was called
the soup
and our guest is
the hilarious joel mchale yes joel's our
guest we used to watch uh the soup oh
god i loved that show back in the day
well i watched the
the john i always want to say jim henson
john henson john hanson he was funny too
so he was great brick in here was funny
yeah you should tyler i don't i didn't
watch that iteration yeah generation
obviously it was great and went on to do
so many other things community
that's a tough one for you i got through
the community yes he was the star of the
show community kind of a classic now it
was a real cult yes that dan harmon
created i don't think it ever got the
greatest ratings but the people who
watched that show were so loyal that's
devoted to it that they in fact they
kept it on the air yeah yeah there was a
pit
the first time i can remember that
happening where there was like an online
petition that was successful to keep the
show going and i just started watching
it and it's yeah it's really funny but
it's very
dense we talk about this where joel and
all those actors are so good at handling
that dialogue it was like
very wordy but he again uh he got his
start on the soup and that's how he
became famous and i think his genius on
that show was that he
if you don't if you're not familiar with
the show it's a show about
other shows that are on like reality
show he he makes fun of shows that are
on tv and little and they play clips and
he but his genius was that he was funny
and he made fun of them but he was never
mean-spirited or nasty and yeah he
remained which is a real skill i think
he's likeable while making fun of things
i was talking about this on pete
holmes's podcast uh pete's point about
some of those mid-2000s movies um
was that it was there was a
mean-spirited quality to some of them
and i disagreed i i think there's
potentially like in in the dialogue like
a vince vaughn movie um or bill murray
maybe the dialogue in the wrong hands
can is mean or or um but i think it's
all about the delivery and i think that
that's the genius of somebody like vince
or owen wilson is that these guys were
able to deliver dialogue like that and
that similar to what joel does yeah like
you're saying on the soup i think it's a
real rare thing and um yeah yes he now
has a uh podcast with ken jong former
doctor current comedic actor ken john
called the darkest timeline
and he also has a movie out a thriller
horror it sounds like a thrill thriller
right yeah called becky yes it sounds
cool i want to see yes it's
streaming and streaming on the services
but first you know uh before i watch
this movie i really want to i want to
hear the interview yeah let's do it
great i want to hear it too
so here we go my uh my talk
with talk subs
you like that yeah it's pretty good you
know
mateo life could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello again shaboom and
you do have a great voice um picking
that up doing so much voice over work oh
that's right i haven't and you have a
great shock of uh like cool kind of
cockatoo hair yeah three surgeries later
and look at my hair
yeah
wait wait wait really oh yeah yeah oh no
well well it worked
why did it take three
oh i'd be i'd be totally bald uh it
takes a lot we're not all born with
gorgeous
thick hair like you are you in your
mid-30s early 30s oh i love you
joel i'm look i know that you're much
younger than me because i used to watch
you know i'll watch like galaxy quest
when i was an adult and you were uh-huh
so
well i was technically an adult when i
did that so i i always looked younger um
i'm 42 so i'm probably not much younger
than you oh i'm 48. uh
so
yeah but you've reached the hair
threshold where there's a pretty good
shot that it's going to be thick for the
rest of your life it's interesting that
you're right to me that you're able to
because i have a friend who
i know had
operation hair
stuff done and um
and it's still very insecure about it
because i think it was before the
technology was such that
you can kind of tell i can't tell with
you
um
it's not well done doing it uh
right right the technology's bananas now
they just pluck your hair and stick it
there
the guy that did mine he's like oh i
spend a lot of time fixing
crappy surgery
go to
a different country
where they're like it's a third of the
cost thank you well i'm joel mchale for
hair transplants
well it's very refreshing to hear
somebody speak honestly about it because
uh like i said the the one person that i
know who's had it done is so he's a
friend of mine and he refuses to
acknowledge it to me and i'm like i
we're friends like how can i trust you i
i know you've had this done why don't we
just talk about it yeah you're like
listen tom cruise
no one's gonna care
yeah c-r-e-w-s um
cruz don't there was a time when i was
like don't tell anyone and i'm like what
am i thinking and so i just abandoned
that and
so i i just well and i'm gonna steer
right into it well it's admirable and uh
i i'm noticing it about you you do it's
great and whoever did it is uh very
talented
when did you start losing it oh 18 19.
oh wow
just as you were on bed
and
no just as i was getting here oh yeah no
it was it was going back and when i
started the soup i look at some of the
promo photos i'm like oh yeah i was a
pretty faithful viewer of the soup and
yeah you did
yeah i guess so yeah maybe i've gone
overboard and this really shows my uh
midlife crisis but i i my theory is that
i'm never gonna die and i think it's a
good theory and i don't think anybody so
far you're right about it yeah
if i'm [ __ ] alive what are you gonna
do
i look like i'm 19.
and well that's got to be the worst part
about losing your hair when you hit
because you have a boy you have a young
face
that's jill's making a coke
come hither
like that's why you don't want to then
have
a kind of an old upper head right
because then you look like uh like a
villain no you have to have a good kid
like if you're patrick stewart or your
co-star uh bruce willis um if you fit
early
that really early and then you're like
oh well that's just how it is and they
have good shaped heads
really yes yes that's always been a
concern of mine if i were to lose my
hair i have like an eggy
kind of oblong shaped um kind of like a
like um
close encounters alien head mine comes
to a point like a canoe you've never had
a roll like in a where you played like a
soldier where your head shaved i shaved
my head for so i shaved my head for a
movie that had that took
place over the course of six years so
they wanted to show a transformation of
looks and
so the the final one was um yeah it was
basically shaved uh i guess it's worse
in my head
i mean in my imagination right um is
that
uh those apple commercials
um
they never shaved it i mean they would i
wonder if i wore a bald i wore a bald
cap once for something um
for uh i steve for a steve jobs thing
for some reason i was bald and i don't
know why um
and i remember thinking or in a horror
movie you know when you get a mold done
of your body you have to wear that
uh and it always looks very odd for me
to have um also a big head but what you
uh
what's your head size for like uh major
league baseball hats the new era uh
that's a good question i remember it
being something like seven and maybe
three quarters does that sound right
that's is that big that's enormous
oh and maybe that's too big seven
half and that's pretty
oh good
oh it's funny that that's your gauge for
things because you
you you played baseball you played
football right well transition
uh
i did play football and the segi goes to
there you go the chloe goes to
uh yeah i didn't play well but i played
fine you what when you played in college
though right
yeah not well uh okay i walked on it's a
long story but you went to university of
washington it's still impressive to me
because it was my fantasy to get to play
organized football and you played my
favorite you played tight end my
favorite position
uh and probably the most
utilitarian
position there's a lot to do i like to
think which is not true but uh i like to
think that we have more
to do we have almost as much to do as
the quarterback there's receiving the
ball there's blocking there's pulling
and uh and then we had a two tight end
offense so it was a formidable
line of guys but i
played one year in high school
and i was like i'm gonna be an actor and
uh so i did that and i played i all i
all i cared about was sports and acting
uh and that's why i was in galaxy quest
as well
uh
were you i was that one dude this is
awkward i call that scene where
the way to bury the lead yeah the aliens
are suffocating in that room you know
sure sure you go to that and then yes
blade runner
i'm i'm right
i'm right there uh i went to university
of washington did not want to i i
shouldn't have gone to college i was
terrible student i was only wanting to
act and play sports but uh
then i was recruited to row i went there
i was like oh i'm gonna be a rower here
and i got rep and i got into a fight
with the varsity rowing team with this
other me two freshmen fought
11 seniors which is what good fight
what why over what what was it about so
my we didn't push a chair in properly uh
no joke this is a very so i think
my theory is that for
sports that are not well watched
uh which rowing is not as popular it's
only popular like every four years i'm
going to really piss off going set it's
popular as a transition shot for like
certain movies like uh
like goodwill hunting in the 80s had a
dude about just finishing on a river uh
somewhere yeah east
um
but
university washington's a very good uh
team and there's a really good book
called the boys in the boat about
the team going to
germany in 1936 for the olympics it
really is that's what the wonderful part
of that program the bad yeah is the
uh the crazy sadistic rituals that they
employed and to know
sort of
uh there was no
guidance or authority over them they
could do whatever they wanted so wow
such as the freshman had to shave if you
got into the freshman boat to the elite
freshman boat you had to shave your head
and your eyebrows and put all that hair
into a pillow and then
the pillow was put into a display case
of other hair pillows much like ed gein
the serial killer yeah yeah um they had
all these [ __ ] rules and
yeah and i was mister i don't care about
any of that let's just bro and i didn't
push a chair in
they surrounded us this guy named jason
reiny and i who is now a successful
lawyer at microsoft and he made
from high school suzanne russell so
congrats to you guys oh jason ryan okay
i just i thought you were outing him as
like one of the the
the guys that you fought against
for as much of uh i like to think that
i'm an evolved human being
but when i think about the time and i
think about those guys it fills me with
rage
yeah yeah
i want i mean i want to be right back
there it's not a isn't that funny that
you think like well i guess i still have
more work to do on myself i need to go
back to counseling because i
certainly
have not worked on this uh right before
we did this i i was i couldn't figure
out the wireless our power had been out
for a few days there was a storm that
moved through and i
when i was younger and um
i'm so bad with technology with with
computers and things and and i
i get so frustrated over it um
and i hadn't had an episode like that in
a while and i thought oh you know
in my arrogance i thought well i guess
i'm doing better i guess i'm uh and i
right before talking to tom before i
talk to you i got so worked up i was so
angry i almost
i liter i almost threw the computer
against the wall um
in in frustration and uh and i it's i
had one of those moments today where i
was like well i guess i haven't really
i feel like i gotta if you really let it
go that's when people who are like
unhealthy or have an issue will have a
heart attack yeah yeah
it's been like like just like an acting
exercise where you're like oh this is
the feeling you get in a murder this is
when you this is when you accidentally
murder someone yes you're filled with
rage and you can't control it
oh joel i was afraid that the neighbors
i was making noises that i thought might
cause the neighbors to call the cops i'm
embarrassed to admit that but i was like
i mean i was like
[ __ ] primal um neighbors like you
know that's just justin long he um he
doesn't think
he can't figure out his wifi again i was
trying to install
the a fix an issue with my 12 year old's
oculus rift
the uh-huh
and
you put it into a pc and
this is how i know how bad it's getting
because my
rage meter is through here and then when
i feel my 12 year old put his hand on my
shoulder and go
gonna be okay dad
i'm like i know i know it's going to be
okay i want to just make this work i
want you to play rec room
don't placate me
comforting me i'm trying to make this
work for you
oh
do you ever think like oh my kids are
going to be so much more because that's
the goal right like that you're you have
offspring that are more
that are better than you that are more
evolved than you and and um
do you ever think like oh they're
already better than me
and they're oh twelve they're not four
yeah i mean it all those cliches
are true about
kids know you better than anyone and all
that
uh they call me out 10 minutes before
i'm going to do something
when i walk in and they're like we know
what you're going to say
and it's an it's a no and and now my
okay well great and
they they can't they yes it's all it's
all wow and my one of my sons are just
like
you're an idiot and i'm like that makes
you half idiot and uh
yeah okay
does it ever get to the point where
you're like well i'm this is
legitimately frustrating that they're
besting me in
in they're matching me in wits and in
humor and are there ever those moments i
well it's a combination of oh i wish i
had gotten a better joke in and
yeah like oh
my son mocking me and i
like they'll watch community name drop
on netflix
i'll get into it watch community and be
like i really like this scene except for
your acting
and
they will
well they do what i do is just undercut
anything that's happening
and yeah
and it so it does actually fill me with
joy and then i realize
because when i was when eddie who's now
15 was first born my dad was like
you're in for it now
[Laughter]
my dad used to call me and my brothers
jerk
just all three of us
were one
large jerk he'd be like hey jerk get up
here and so it made me and you'd all
answer to it you'd all run yeah we would
just be like okay we wouldn't we just
knew we were jerks and
made wonderful sense it's so funny to
imagine now because i obviously i don't
know your father and all i know about
him is that he was the dean of students
at loyola uh university's rome center
my dad was a professor my dad
loved rome was a seminarian studied in
rome and
my perception of your father is probably
somebody who's closer to my dad but
somebody who calls all three of their
kids jerk
is not that um
what was he like beyond that like did he
have a different side when he was an
academic when he was an administrator uh
at the school i imagine he had to be a
little bit more
polished seeming yeah i mean he was
raised
as was i raised irish catholics so
yeah you know where
as you know they're they're they have
one hand towards god and then the other
hand towards organized crime so
um
no he saw roman holiday in a movie
theater in high school and pointed at
the screen and said that's where i'm
going
and you're kidding he was in chicago and
found a way to do it through loyola
university which has their campus right
up right in chicago so it was really
just that the he kind of fetishized rome
and that just from that movie yes he saw
chicago and he was like wait there's a
place that looks like that all the time
and he was always a big traveler and
became a much bigger traveler after that
because they saw
you know once you had a jumping off
point of italy then you can go
so many places that are so different so
close but so that's where you were born
that's where i was born my brother's wow
yeah my mom was a student at loyola
university
oh boy but he was like you know it
wasn't like he was an older he wasn't
that much older he was like
like one of the he was like an r.a
basically and
but as you were saying like
many of my dad's friends entered
the seminary and not too many actually
became priests but a few did and
yeah so he loved that war he loved the
world of roman catholicism in rome my
mom was there and we got born and
they my dad wasn't making any money so
we had i think they very much they had
to make a big choice whether they wanted
to raise americans or italians because
we couldn't afford
the american or british schools and it
was not in public schools so they
decided to move to
uh rockin
seattle in
1976 or five which wow
yeah seattle was not a blip it literally
there was such a downturn in the economy
in seattle that there was billboards up
around town that said with the last
person to leave seattle please turn the
lights off
oh my god what why because had it been
like a logging industry or so it had
some industry move down
and then you know then the oil crisis
hit and wow every industry took a hit
and logging always
was fine um but boeing was like the huge
engine there was really no other game in
town
of you knowing at that point and
my dad worked for warehouses he worked
for the big logging company uh that was
the job he was able to get and he told
me that when he was driving because
if you're in seattle in sleepy seattle
in the winter it is dark and cold and
raining all the time and he left
swinging rome
subtropical rome
and uh he was he literally told me he's
like he said out loud in our
dodge ass or in our microman he said the
fun times of my life are over
oh
my god
and he was serious you knew he was
serious no he told me the story years
later because he said it alone
did he tell you that story in the
context of like well sometimes you say
things you don't mean or i don't think
he was joking
wow but why did they pick seattle then i
mean like there are certainly more
temperate climates like they're places
in the states that are if they want
american kids they don't want you to be
raised as italians like yeah it's kind
of bananas i think it's because my
grandfather so they my mom is canadian
and from vancouver and my grandfather
and my dad
secure a job in seattle which is oh
south
and so i think that's how that all came
together and now they freak you know
seattle is this
sparkling gem of a city for the most
part of course it has all sorts of
issues but um
but it's it's this idyllic you know now
you've got like microsoft starbucks
amazon uh the supersonics oh
yeah sorry
sorry
um
nhl team the kraken
oh wait really is that true yeah they
named it the cracking which um you know
there's a lot of fracking there's a lot
of debate in seattle but
boyd and brad whenever they have to take
a dump they're like i'm gonna go release
the kraken
sure sure
wow so you must have seen quite a change
i mean as a kid a kid in the 70s in this
in this sleepy seattle
did you see it change over to the kind
of my perception of seattle's you know
the grunge movement and
kurt cobain and stuff like that did you
get to see it have that
hipster heyday well we moved from
seattle in 1978 to new jersey uh
right we moved to
haddonfield new jersey which is right
outside of philadelphia and my we loved
it because it snowed and because you
could trick or treat after school on
halloween you just went from school to
trick-or-treating it was crazy instead
of waiting but my parents all that's
when they realized how much they loved
seattle and obviously philadelphia is a
great town and it has changed a lot
since the 70s
um but
uh but they went back to seattle because
they realized they loved it and
they and so that was i was still like
i don't know a second grade a third
grader oh so you were like [ __ ] i missed
the snow and the trick-or-treating yeah
i was like i was gonna go back it was
weird because i was weird because i was
in seattle and i knew i was supposed to
be a mariners fan but we moved to
philadelphia and the philippines were
like we've won the world series i'm like
i can't just jump on this bandwagon
conflict but then no i saw we it was
very because in seattle you didn't
realize that
you didn't realize that like no big
bands would ever come through like you
two would go san francisco vancouver
oh my god that's so funny yeah so you
just took it for granted that you had
you would always go to rock shows of
your local bands and
yeah you know was that it's not all that
cliche but
i remember booing allison chains off the
stage so this band called the young
fresh fellows could they were the most
popular band in seattle and oh my god
elaine staley going like this music is
[ __ ] great you [ __ ] will see
i remember seeing pearl jam and they
were
on the cover of time and like ready
better walks out he's like hey i guess
we're the most popular band on the
planet and then they went right into
evenflo and i was like oh this is it was
so much fun
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wandery app
[Music]
hello hello again
that was your coming of age during that
time right like um yeah because nirvana
had had bleach come out and
uh they had already had a couple of hits
in seattle
off of
that sliver was a huge hit in seattle
so uh like sound garden i wonder what
what was it about seattle i mean was it
just that it had this experience of
depression and it was kind of like
decrepit for a while and so
it gave rise to a lot of like artistic
voices like angry kind of like pent up
what do you know why that happened in
seattle during that time why it was such
a fertile
place for music i don't that's a good
question i think it's because seattle
was in a box canyon
in that big musicians did not come there
and someone was always considered a
sleepy little town so
every sleepy little town has to
entertain itself
and it just
was like and i remember
in like 1990
a like the seattle weekly had a picture
of
mickey mouse and minnie mouse
with cameras as if there were tourists
and all the seattle uh monuments behind
them and it just said we're coming
when nirvana and pearl jam hit at the
same time
and they hit in such a massive way i
mean smells like team spirit was the
number one song on the planet all of a
sudden you had oh these two bands have
these two big hits and i think that
genera and then of course soundgarden
was right there and
i don't know and then there's the
festival have you been to that sasquatch
festival i've never been to sasquatch oh
i loved it god was that fun um i don't
bumper shoot and the folk life festival
every year for like
20 years i mean it was every year we
were just like in junior high we just
we're all we all would get on a bus and
we all go to seattle center and
just hang out all day and eventually
lose our shirts and our shoes from
dancing in mosh pits and yeah and then
my mom and dad wouldn't even think about
it they were like how you doing and
they're like fine what is your shirt i'm
like
you didn't want us to be italians yeah
or i wonder what gosh if we were at can
you think about like isn't it amazing
that like i mean so few people have such
a clear
hypothetical other life that they could
have had you know like that's such a
clear example of like you'd be a totally
i mean who knows what you would but like
that there was a point in time where
somebody on your behalf made a decision
for you to go this way yeah all my mom
my mom's sisters and brother stayed in
italy oh wow they stayed in europe for
the most part except for one of my mom's
sisters did eventually move back but my
aunt and uncle still live in italy and
my cousin who looks exactly like me and
is almost as tall is
he's a full italian i mean he is
around rome later on you know like in
the last few and when you walk around
rome italians would look at him
like he was some sort of freak because
he was speaking perfect roman italian
and they would stare at him going like
how is this possible that the whitest
dude is
nailing this dialect and now wow yeah so
now my uncle my canadian they live in
africa and my my cousin now lives in
barcelona and all the other ones living
in london and so my mom was the only one
to move back oh my god so
do you see that family a lot do you i
mean obviously not now but like are you
close with them are you yeah well my mom
my grandmother died like four years ago
and that was last time i saw everybody
in person so i saw them all last sunday
on a zoom call uh what we were going to
do is have everybody come to los angeles
this november for
thanksgiving which i don't think is
happening and that's like it's like
25 family members all eating and all
trying not to kill each other and uh
so it it it's good it's a great time but
that's not going to happen is is that in
that must be intimidating to cook for i
just recently started cooking
a lot i mean i used to cook occasionally
but like i just really fallen in love
with it but that must be i would imagine
and maybe maybe i'm stereotyping but i
would be much more intimidated to cook
for a whole table full of europeans and
italians especially so the italians
haven't ever
they haven't come my aunt my other aunt
has uh
but i am a snob and i i love cooking and
so we're planning
that meal
uh month out so oh wow and the turkey
that i get
okay so it's an entire turkey broken
down every piece of meat is removed raw
then they take a ball of stuffing they
take the meat put it around the stuffing
then they take the turkey skin
it looks like a round bread so it's
about this big i get oh my god look at
those and then you cut into it like a
pie it is just all shoved into this
pillow basically oh my god oh hold on
here it is
well he's jill's showing me that oh my
god oh oh so it's the turkey on the
outside
so
turkey's on the outside that's oh it's
all held together by string it looks
like there's some rosemary or maybe
there's a rose just but it's it's
basically it's a yeah the string
it looks like a garlic it looks like a
big garlic it does look like a huge
piece of garlic and that thing yeah that
thing weighs about
18 pounds
so what am i saying so i
sorry so joe i know we're jumping around
a lot um
the fight i'm curious about the fight uh
that you so had you shaved your head yet
had they made you do that i had made the
boat at that point okay they were such
dicks and
after the fight
it was more just slapping around it
wasn't like they were beating us um i
was in a fraternity for three whole
months and i went back to the fraternity
and it did i was just like well here's
what happened and i was expecting other
fraternity brothers like let's go get
them and they were like we should call
the cops and i was like
good that was assault and
then there was like a talk the next day
and this i called the coach and the
coach did nothing and so i was just like
[ __ ] this i'm not gonna be around bulls
so in my fraternity it was a big
football fraternity and they said oh you
should come out they're like hey you
should come up football
and uh because uh university of
washington had a very serious walk-on
program so they're like you should try
it and because at that point i'm like
225 pounds or something
and so i went out there not and i didn't
really know how to play football which
is not a good place to be but i could
see the cannon fodder of other players
that were going out there
and they i was like you kind of could
see the guys that were gonna get blown
away
and so i
i had a great i didn't get killed thank
god um but the guys i was very good at
practicing and
showing the defense
the plays of the other team and it made
them feel very good about it
but the two guys ahead of me
were
world-class athletes who both wowed into
the nfl both won super bowls and both
were terrifying athletes no who who was
that joel mark bruner who was captain of
the steelers and oh eventually went to
the texans he was like he's like six six
he was like six six two eighty oh my god
he's a 22 year old and he and the backup
guy the number two
was
a more intimidating athlete his name was
ernie conwell and he's 6-2 he won a
super bowl with the rams
at 21 now and mark bruno is going to
argue with that because but 20 i
remember mark bruner yeah ernie could
bench press 500 squad a thousand and he
was running a 4-5 40-yard dash at two
holy
yeah tight ends they're huge they're
it's a massive position i at that you're
how tall are you six four they were so i
was a little taller than ernie but ernie
ernie is one of those guys when you
shook his hand his the hand muscle was i
watched him clean and jerk 365 and so
this is a 21 year old in 1992
so oh my god and i was just like god
have mercy on the people that he's gonna
run into because
well i mean they both i mean and mark
bruner was the starter and he would
he was such he was uh like a chiro
suzuka who used to be on the mariners
who was a tiny little guy but had the
best
arm because he just knew how to use his
body that's how bruno was he just knew
how to move guys and catch and
they're and
they're still i know them uh i've see i
see over the years that like seahawks
practices because they both work for the
nfl well one of them works for this uh
mark now works for the piece of scout
for pittsburgh but um and so
did being on the team that kind of time
commitment did it also not allow you to
to act i mean you said that those were
that was one of your two
lies
the only thing i ignored was school it's
really good oh
i did i cheated all through college
uh because i hated it and i'm super
dyslexic and
uh so i couldn't read so that so i was
just like i'll just cheat and
uh so i did acting at night i did plays
and i did a ton of improv theater in
seattle that had a very rough scene
uh at this place called unexpected
productions and um so that i did that
every single i was there every single
night football really taught me how to
manage my time and that when i was doing
something i would do it incredibly
uh hard and then
into the next thing it's funny because i
just started re-watching i had
my relationship with the show community
was like i had seen an episode here and
there and like always liked it there was
no reason why i hadn't
sat down and started watching it but as
you said it's on netflix now so i
i knew i was going to be talking to you
and i started watching it and i um
i've come to really appreciate
why it's such a popular show i like i'm
three episodes in and i really am
enjoying it but um
it strikes me everything you're saying
it's very similar to the character
you're playing on that show
this guy who is
kind of a rule breaker and and a kind of
a bill murray character um
literally
oh no kidding yeah that's why his last
name is winger oh okay yeah
uh oh wow i watched stripes before i
auditioned for it a bunch
just go like right and i yes i would say
that part is very similar
uh to
me uh in the cheating part definitely i
could relate to that uh very easily
when i got that script i'm sure you this
happens to you where i go
no matter what happens i know i can do
this
how do you go from so you're at
washington you graduate right right
and then at what point do you are you
still just doing improv and you're
looking for work i got a job on a local
sketch comedy show
on nbc
that was on at 11 30 on saturday nights
and would push snl to 12 o'clock
called almost live and they oh
yeah
it's a very it was
short-lived on comedy central because
all the
references were to neighborhoods in
seattle and
it was this remarkably funny
group of people and i was an intern
and they took pity on me and allowed me
to work there so i had this long job on
television
just right out of college and wow
so lucky
well well joe you say they took pity on
you but obviously that you know you're
being humble they
they saw something in you because they
put you on camera then yeah yeah
as an intern i started writing sketches
and making sure i made made it into them
oh wow and and while you were doing that
was it like oh i'm this is it this is
what i want to be doing was it just uh
kind of a fantasy situation could not
believe i was being paid
to [ __ ] around and yeah i couldn't
believe it i was so so i got very yeah
very lucky
early on and you know obviously if i
suck they probably would have fired me
um so i did that right out of college
and wow
three years into that i thought i really
probably should go to los angeles and i
should get good at acting
and go to los angeles um so i
went to graduate school
uh at the university of washington or
yeah this is interesting to me because
at this point you're like you're making
money doing this thing you're having
success
what about what you were doing
i mean i i think it's admirable that you
did have that instinct to want to
get better and trained but like
what about your experience um
made you feel like you needed to do that
i sucked
oh well how'd you fight you why did it
why why did you think that i mean how
did you i think every actor has the
affliction of
i you are always feel that tug
of you need to be doing something more
uh and
i knew i don't know it just was because
i knew that i had to give it a shot on a
bigger scale
and
uh i
knew that like these graduate schools
for acting you would just
you could just go act for three years
that was my impression of what it was
um
and so
the yeah it was just this tug that i
needed to try it
because i knew that it was like the show
was great locally and it was
popular it was really crazy because i
all of a sudden started getting
recognized
i was just like look at me and um
but i knew
i knew that
it wasn't gonna last forever
and
i needed to
do i needed to try bigger so i quit and
went to graduate school because i know
how hard it is to get on a show like
that and to to find that kind of success
uh and i'm sure a lot of actors
listening are like wait a minute you had
this you had a bird in the hand he had
like a really successful thing um
what about what you were doing on that
made you feel like you weren't
good or i'm not saying you you were you
weren't but well i wanted to do i knew i
wanted to do more than sketch com i
really want to be broader in my
uh skill set to be able yeah to do more
and believe me when i like i got to la
and i had all these tapes and um of me
doing sketches and no one was interested
i didn't have an agent
i had a commercial agent and they were
[ __ ] great aka here in la
uh mike abrams and uh doug uh so
uh no i but none of that none of the
local stuff really translated uh
and so i was i was working in a wine
shop in larchmont uh um
in nine you know in 2000. by the way why
do you have an all about steve poster
behind you oh because ken jong and i do
a podcast and i like get different movie
posters of his
oh that's funny that's funny
um the whole thing uh but i i literally
couldn't get an agent i would meet with
these agents and
and they were just not interested and
they were like you're a commercial actor
i got with them one agency that i signed
with
a year before this two years before the
soup and then they dropped me because
they were like come back they literally
said come back when you're bigger
because this this agency is too big for
you so how did you get even the audition
for the soup
the annie roberts who was and continues
to be the casting director at e saw my
commercials and just like as you know
like names get passed around just like
oh that guy can tell a couple of jokes
yeah one of i don't know 20 auditions
that he said will you come in and
make fun of uh it was all you know like
it was it was always like make fun it
was early on in reality television but
yeah all these specials where com you
know people comics just kind of
commented on things and so it was just a
one of many auditions
wow and was it after was it to replace
john henson i'm trying to remember now
aisha tyler
came after john well when
uh
when john and then powell and then aisha
before that was oh yeah hal sparks yeah
great kaneer obviously started it in 91
but it ended in 2002 it was done
and then
in 2004 they started like we want to
bring back a version of the soup that's
not called this
[Music]
a new president came in and said we
should call it the soup all right
so when you got that job
was there a part of you that was
thinking oh this will be this is
something that all those people you
mentioned aisha
house sparks went on to queer as folk
and obviously greg kinnear had a great
acting career did did you consider that
like a launching pad um i literally
thought if i can do
half or a quarter or an eighth of what
tanir did because obviously he went from
hosting a
cable show to yeah you know as good as
it gets uh to oscar nominations so i was
like oh if i could do if i can use this
platform to get other stuff because i
could not even get in the room for
like the third friend on
a dane cook pilot which was you know he
had a pilot ever i only say him because
he had a pilot every year he did yeah
yeah and it was always like too many
cooks in the kitchen it was always like
something like cheese
i couldn't even get
a reading i mean i couldn't even get
into i thought if i just get on
television and do because i asked some
active friends like would you do this
kind of
soup talk suit thing and they're like oh
absolutely not i would never do that i'm
like yeah i'm gonna do it and uh
and that that obviously all of a sudden
i was on people's radars because yeah
and and i know it sounds like i'm taking
like oh this would be my platform for
the next thing but i you know i stayed
with i want it i loved doing it and
people was like do you like acting or
the soup better i'm like why can't i
like everything life could be a dream
sweetheart
[Music]
i've done some acting i then went and
did like some hosting stuff and i have
been struck
by how
similar the two are i mean like you're
telling jokes you're having to
be relatable and funny and and
personable
on your own like without you have an
audience you can refer to sort of
but like for the most part it's it's you
having to hold people's attention and i
i think there's a lot of acting in
involved in that um
was that something that dan harmon saw
that did dan recognize that or was that
just an audition no that was uh dan
harmon's girlfriend aaron hill at the
time they're not together obviously um
she was a fan and said that's your jeff
winger that's the guy who's being all
sarcastic and
uh telling jokes he's like that's that's
the guy you want and so that's why i got
the audition
yeah nbc didn't why there i was not high
on their list though uh
wow they had other choices and but i was
dan and the russo brothers choice so
um
i was that they were they they were
thankfully you know like they were my
champions for it they've been a russian
development obviously and they had a
couple of very good movies if they were
directing studio movies so they yeah
there's no coincidence that they're as
big as they are because they both
exude
direction and
confidence and they know what they want
they know how they knew how to make
stuff funny and good and
i mean between harman and them for those
that first year was and and second year
was
it was pretty great
if you could boil down their direction
or their comedic uh perspective
i would imagine that there was a focus
put on
making it real uh making that because
some of that stuff is is pretty written
but it's all very grounded in in the
performances um joe
taught me
when he was directing because the
scripts were so dense with jokes they
were like yeah like an animated
uh series but all they're all
character-driven jokes it wasn't just
well this is a good time to put this one
in because it makes sense it's
more coming out of the people but joe
would always say
good
cut do it again twice as fast that
technical note really informed us all i
think to just
zip along and that really did it i saw
this lawrence olivier documentary and
he's they go over his whole crazy
amazing career and at the end he's super
old and the last question is
for young actors out there what advice
do you have for them and he just he
pauses and he just goes speed up
and i think actors like we enjoy these
moments you're like oh this is so cool
it's just a big huge moment but you
don't realize that in those big huge
moments in your life your brain is going
a thousand miles an hour all the time
yeah
and you are also having to
manage these lines that people usually
don't say i mean like
it's dense it's packed with these jokes
i was thinking even like um danny
danny
he's like a robot i mean he's got stuff
that he's and he's gonna make that human
yeah but that is a real uh challenge as
an actor and that i think that's why
it makes sense to me why so many of you
came out the other end of that and like
with with great success uh
what's great is that dan establishes
this group of broken people who are all
trying to just be in a study group but
then it gets
so it's so great because the study group
remains the same but it is
the the levels that dan takes the show
to as far as
absurdity and fantasy and wonderment is
yeah all i could ever hope for was it
always a joy to do was there ever did
you ever have to sense like five seasons
in where you were like uh i you know i
think that i'm good um i could i
never wanted it to end
uh-huh
i i i was i really could have gone
10 years on it i would have done it um
wow i was never there was other people i
mean obviously donald knew what he was
doing and yeah
yeah so weird like why would you get off
a network show you're on television he's
like no i want to become the biggest
star on the planet
good luck with all that
i remember him saying he was like you
know being like will smith he did all
this stuff i'm like yeah he's like
that's what i want to do i'm like oh
yeah it makes sense it all yeah
[Laughter]
um but you know i would have done it
forever uh i really did i the hours were
bananas
yeah i bet i bet we're making a movie
every week and i don't know his
experience on ed but we were shooting
four episodes like we were shooting the
tail end of an episode we're in the main
episode we were picking up shots from
three weeks ago and yeah it was i
remember going into my trailer and there
would be ten
those study room scenes would take a day
oh i bet i bet i bet i bet directors
like justin lin coming in he directed
our paintball up he directed a bunch of
him but he directed her wow
oh right
this guy is a [ __ ]
genius expert a visionary yeah and so
and they they always were trying to shut
them down and they were like it shuts
down now we're pulling the power now and
they'd walk out and he'd be like all
right let's keep going uh jeffy chase
are you sick of talking about chevy
chase i never get asked about him
weird
yeah well i i i only because i've heard
snippets of things and like i've heard
from other people i know he's he is
famously difficult i feel like at this
point it's like
yes everyone kind of knows that he's
difficult and dan obviously has talked
about it um yeah
no he definitely he like he didn't and
he would say it in the press that yeah
he did not like he didn't want to be
there that long
alone was an impediment uh and i don't
think he would disagree with what i'm
saying and right he wanted to get out of
there as fast as he could just as
someone who's been on similar days at
what point during the day
would he start to get a little antsy
like 10 minutes in
uh
no it would
he would
look and he was older than us and we
were yeah and you know half the cast was
in their mid 20s and i was in my mid 30s
so um
you know we obviously had more energy
and he was
so uh
but yeah he we would he would get shot
out yeah a lot of his stuff is in
singles i've noticed that song yeah yeah
no that yeah yeah so but uh he
definitely
didn't didn't want to be there as much
as i mean like the hours were
finished but
yeah i was always like the hours are the
hours
yeah
this is how it is we're not gonna yeah
yes we we should all i mean we should
all be thanking our lucky stuff i mean
is that true the
famous thing is like if you want if you
want to hear an actor complain give him
a job
and yeah
so
but so yeah he didn't want to be that he
didn't like his character at all oh well
then you'd always talk about it was
character was an [ __ ] and we're like
well
chubby uh so
now
now he says he likes that so
um
he yeah and again i don't think he would
disagree because he said it all over the
i've heard him say yeah i know but but
then it begs the question
joe then i always think like
and i've thought this about co-stars
i've had like
why are you doing it like why do it you
know i mean certainly in specifically
with with chevy in this case like uh
you you you read the script
you know what's involved like
presumably he he knew what those hours
were like it's like why do it he must be
loaded obviously for people in our
position to get on a show that actually
is working and is going right up it is
like hitting a grand slam three times a
row in yankee stadium and people just
take it for granted that
you just get these jobs and it just
happens that is right not how it works
and
actors that work consistently and make
really good money have platinum
horseshoes stuck up their ass
we all know really talented actors that
have not made it that have not gotten
that break or whatever but to get those
breaks is very hard and
so many different ingredients go into
getting that role
when i hear people complain about it i'm
just like
a welder can complain about the hours uh
yeah and but you know there's free food
everywhere actors get their trailers and
lie down okay if you've been on a i
don't know some sort of like drama for
12 years i get that you might want to
not do it anymore well because forget
the like maybe they're sick of having to
do the say that similar lines or
it was same outcome and this character
hasn't advanced or whatever but like the
lifestyle it's hard to compete with that
lifestyle i mean the
and the camaraderie and like the sense
of well community like you know the
those crews are [ __ ] it's like a fun
family and i i think everybody
recognized for the most part recognizes
that we're all kind of lucky to be here
and when i hear those stories about
somebody who is like
clearly not think feeling that way um
and i always marvel at how having done
it for so long i'm like how how could
you
how could you look that gift horse in
the mouth you know
you and i both know horror stories about
different actors in
in hollywood and
if you hear one story about someone it's
probably right if you hear right 100
stories about someone it's true
right and i don't know what they just
need to go get counseling or something
right
right it is that thing don't do it and
uh yeah it it's it is for because so
many people are in jobs they hate but
they have to do it to provide for their
families and their lives and but
of course and but in this case too it
also must have been like i imagine it
was a bummer because like i'm sure you
grew up watching chevy chase movies the
way i did the way you know i'm sure dan
harmon did and it's like
oh dude
come on i [ __ ] look up to you i you
know uh
it's a bummer and a quote flesh back to
him and yeah i could quote
yeah i mean there's so many he's in so
many funny movies and i mean
i played him in a movie and i had to
study
the young chevy chase and he is
astonishing he's so yeah
what what movie was that joel it was
called a stu a futile and stupid gesture
oh yeah of course yeah the david wayne
movie david wings movie the great david
yeah yeah and uh will forte played this
guy named doug kenny who of course
invented national lampoon he wrote
animal house and then he wrote and
produced caddyshack and then he died
very young tragically for comedy nerds
yeah you should check it out it's on
netflix emmy rossum's great that's right
man you're really good in that uh
so you obviously kept in touch with ken
um what was the motivation for you guys
to do the darkest timeline uh the
podcast you're doing uh we're both uh
workaholic obsessive compulsive though
we both had tons of stand up hooked and
obviously that disappeared
i said let's do this podcast now uh
his wife was like you should do that and
it would it kept us away from our
families for two hours a day which they
were very thankful for
and uh and you get to cut you get to
like [ __ ] with your friend i mean i
imagine that's just like and he's a
doctor and we really wanted to talk
about covid and what exactly was
happening because there's so much
information all the time so i would be
like i read about this and then he would
as an actual doctor be able to actually
talk about it that's fine i can't wait
to hear i want to listen um yeah and you
also you have becky coming out an action
thriller came out a couple months ago mr
long because of covid it was one of the
only movies in drive-ins and at one
point
oh these articles are like becky's going
to be the number one movie
of the month of july or something
because they're like it's raped in 100
000
and
it's a tiny movie but
wow
i loved it because these directors are
great and if you there's a great movie
on netflix called bushwick starring dave
batista and britney snow
it's great
really okay bushwick wait i uh dave is a
pal i uh
i want to it showed i was like oh dave
batista can do almost anything that's oh
wow okay bushwicks
you know then they cast kevin james is a
neo-nazi in
an escaped
nazi from a prison and
uh he home invades
this house with uh my daughter who
played played by lulu wilson and my my
wife was played by amanda rugel who's
brilliant and uh wow lulu wilson is a
[ __ ] movie star she's 15 and she is
she's great and wow wait um joel wait so
so kevin plays a white supremacist yeah
wow okay so that's on
it's in drive-ins but it's also on
streaming yeah i mean it got released a
while ago but it did i mean obviously
it's one of those things where it's so
funny is horrible but
these weird surprises happen where
yeah i mean it would be like if you had
said to a toilet paper company in
january
oh you're never going to be able to make
this
why is there a diarrhea epidemic no no
no it's just people are scared that
they're gonna run out of this this is it
yeah
yeah
yeah it's one of the few little
but that's the thing about these little
tiny little bright spots in this [ __ ]
storm it's like
we should dwell on these things so yeah
becky um
and and you're all blessed to watch star
girl
and star wait star girl we promote that
and that's with um well uh
uh her name last name is passenger brett
bassinger who's the star
uh and then owen wilson uh luke wilson
and amy smart and a bunch of other
really
great actors and that's a that's a
that's a what do you call it a dc comic
anyway have you guys been i mean you're
in l.a how how locked down have you been
like are your kids pretty locked up i
mean yeah yeah relatively
we have people over but we all keep
distance and stuff and we've i've had
multiple tests and so was the family so
you had mentioned earlier you got you
just got the test was that for work was
that for a job uh
for a reality show uh called
i guess it's called fast booties i guess
it's a new show but basically they take
your favorite fast food and recreate it
and i don't i really don't know well
that'd be fun for you because you are
sounds like kind of a foodie i am a
[ __ ] snob and
yeah my wife's birthday was this week so
we're having some friends over tonight
uh and away from each other but i'm
gonna cook a bunch of wagyu beef so i
would love to your expertise as i said
just getting into this but uh practice
practice
how did you cultivate that why did you
where did you get that come from your
parents if i wasn't going to be an actor
i wanted to be a chef ah huh yeah i love
doing it i buy lots of stuff and do lots
of research so i know you got to go and
cook this is just like lightning round
formula
what is your most commonly used emoji
would you say
or do you not use emojis i do not uh
when i when it comes to an opportunity
for an emoji i will just go prayer hands
you know for thank you if you could be
uh a professional athlete what sport
would you play uh and and why right now
would it be football
no
yeah i think
my first love was probably being a
professional tennis player
because of the
the attention they got what
i think if i don't know
you must have gotten attention in high
school though you must have been popular
i became popular not at first i i had a
few friends that were very
that i i was very close to and we kind
of protected each other and we slowly
became popular and then by here i'm like
oh it's look at look at us um
uh huh what were your brothers
in the same high school we were all in
the same high school at one time
uh oh wow
so we were we were all over the place i
was held back and because they thought i
would because my dyslexia was no fun
oh yeah it literally told me that i was
a slow starter they said that to my face
that i was slow
so that was a wonderful cycle oh my god
wow when you were how old second grade
jesus and so how did you manage your
dyslexia now i mean does it
now i'm proud of it now i embrace it i
mean you eventually do learn to read but
boy the it would take me four hours to
get through 20 minutes of jokes on
the suit when i first started because
and you know like intimidation and
nervousness and how am i gonna get
through this and thank you wow he was
very cool about it and
said just do your thing
uh eventually you do learn how to read
uh when you practice it enough and then
we were doing the shows live the the
soup and so i would promote it with my
dyslexia i'd be like oh
yeah i don't know how this is gonna go i
can't read so here we go and yeah oh
yeah i i suppose i always thought you
were joking
no
yeah
i see a script i need to have it in
advance not uh not a not a memorized
script but like if it's a teleprompter
thing i need to oh wow
well i'm sure that that is true of
community too because they're like we
were saying that those jokes are so
that's the scripts were so dense and
you carried
all of those episodes seemingly so you
don't have to memorization is different
than
uh reading so
memorizing i actually read very slowly
but i remember everything so that was
always easy i didn't have to unless it
was really technical
then
that's all that was always a stumbling
block for me or
but um i would be painstakingly going
over them beforehand oh wow
you know like conan or or jimmy kimmel
or some of those guys they can just
flip right through it no pro just like
it is nothing yeah but i wonder if that
might have been like a weird asset to
you because you seem like we're talking
about there there is acting involved and
you were able to um
you had a possession of it that was
maybe
i definitely had to re-read it numerous
times yeah ah yeah i mean like on 120
page script it takes a day if i have to
get through it i mean i read it there
and go through it
no wonder you haven't read um the movie
we're doing together yeah i can't wait
i think it's like a star wars thing
anyway wow all right well i will
definitely check that out um
if you uh
so it'd be tennis you think i played so
many sports endlessly if it had a ball i
was throwing it or catching it so
at different times i had a love affair
with baseball i played endless amounts
of basketball
are you still a mariners
american mariners fan they're on tonight
at six playing the astros and um no i
think all but ultimately i watch so much
football now but yeah cox won the super
bowl i was i had so much joy that it was
unnatural if you could have one snack
food for the rest of your life what
would it be joe well if it could be
anything it would be spaghetti carbonara
oh wow you make one food and it's it's a
you know it's a it's it is it's a a dish
of pasta like creamy pasta right
no it take you take hot ham eddie a ham
or bacon peas and then you have a layer
of you crack eggs the spaghetti can't be
too hot and then you put it into the
the raw eggs and it coats all the pasta
and slightly cooks it but not overcooks
it and if it's done right
it's the greatest what's the movie that
cause i often ask this question what's
your favorite movie and people get very
upset
jill's pointing to it all about the all
about steve poster behind him it looks
like you're at a press junket from and
it's like 12 years ago thanks for asking
justin i had a great time with sandy
she's wonderful
and uh you know this bradley as i call
him you know b cooper uh he's going
places what a great nickname for bradley
cooper yeah he's just just salt of the
earth i [ __ ] love him i love all of
them you think he's gonna be successful
that handsome talented guy behind you uh
you know you never
you just you know you get a feeling and
uh i think you know he's special
um what uh
what is the movie that you're excited to
like show your kids that that you think
um
that me that's
i would say like during quarantine like
the most like a real comfort movie
well we're about to show them breakfast
club which they have
so that is very exciting
i showed them master and commander which
i always loved
them to see that that's interesting to
follow up yeah master and commander with
a clockwork orange they're gonna love
that yeah you know wait
have you seen breakfast club in a while
no not in a while maybe 10 years but it
holds up it i'm excited for i saw it
recently and i'm like [ __ ] this is good
dance montage
even the dance montage yeah
well it's been parodied so many times
and i know that they're like uh the kids
might if they're not used to i just grew
up on those movies so it was like to me
it doesn't seem that strange to have
that montage and
they watch the matrix a lot they love
them
huh if you had to live somewhere else
where would it be i'd love to say
seattle which is my hometown
i would love to be able to go like japan
or
saw you know somewhere in europe uh uh
that would be great um
let's just say the maldives how does
that sound okay all right uh i you said
that your kids tease you about um you
know they're like snarky about you on
the show but do they like community like
do they get into it do you like
community yeah
it was always weird because i was always
making out with women that weren't my
wife so my 12 year old now i mean this
was a couple years ago he would just
stand up and walk out of the room and
then come back
yeah that must be weird uh if you if you
could have dinner with three people dead
or alive whom you've never met who would
they be i'm gonna say julia roberts dead
okay
okay uh they're alive that's true that
is true uh there's something uh it's
very ominous answer but um
uh
don't tell her okay well she won't she
want to hear this
i don't know
yeah that's a tough one that's that's a
bad lightning round question because it
requires a lot of thought
and ever well this is a this is a more
intense one uh who is your favorite
muppet uh robin
oh yeah kermit's son nephew or whatever
hey here's robin uh yeah who was he
related to how was he related to kermit
because kermit didn't have
no
didn't birth him
he'd be half a pig i don't know who my
favorite robin was a pure frog as far as
i could tell animal maybe ah
yeah
oh that i know that says about you
oh it's so great because we just cut we
wasn't even playing drums all the time
just going yeah yeah just jill's just
panting
yeah yeah uh this is fun okay wait wait
really quick uh my apologies uh two
minutes uh would you rather be called
unattractive or unfunny probably
unattractive
i'll take it over on boy uh which golden
girl do you must identify with dorothy
blanche rose or sophia
i feel like they cover all sorts of
different parts of me uh
be arthur i mean uh what's uh dorothy uh
yeah she was
yeah they kind of sassy st uh pragmatic
tweet her and betty white they just yeah
yeah they're all really good that show
holds up
and do you ever think about legacy and
how you want to be remembered um i know
you have kids do you ever think about
how you might be perceived
i don't know um i mean it does go back
to that hope i'm a good dad and uh yeah
i hope i'm a good husband to my wife
you're currently not being it's her
birthday yeah i know okay well [ __ ] man
have a great this i know it's so
enjoyable i had i literally started
cooking before
i'm cooking a pile of onions this big
that so they'll be reduced down and the
steaks have been sit they're out so the
steaks are room temperature and i'm
cooking salmon and chicken so it's all
there this is all it's all fine
okay yeah thanks buddy this is great
let's do it again i'd love to be on your
show with ken oh you're going to be
believe me okay okay all right that
sounds like a threat this is one of the
one of the reasons why i wanted to come
on was to
now we have an introduction so okay all
right you just looked very sinister yeah
you'll be on you believe me
all right well
okay buddy thank you this was really fun
well
well that just happened
christian just said i wish you had eaten
you're a little low energy jab
and speaking of the bushes hey nice good
connection all right justin hasn't eaten
eaten yet his blood sugar is low so uh
he's sipping what is that coffee coffee
yeah coffee coffee sustains me now see
now i'm going to be extra i'm sorry
sorry i'm going to push it i shouldn't
have planted this no no i let's go this
is good uh that was enjoyable you guys
seem like you could be friends i think
it sounds like you guys should have a
talk uh cooking show together oh that
would be fun i would like i like how
into cooking he is me too you know paul
doesn't like that he's into cooking
he's very impressive he's very affable
isn't he yes and don't you love that
just the way i i liked him
right away like right off the bat when
he admitted to getting their hair
plugged amazing amazing you know how i
feel about people admitting to vanity
yes we in fact had a guest on the show
who was very upset about a um that's
true we had a guest justin
posted a photo of someone once and um it
revealed an unflattering part of their
head follicle shortcomings and
that person was very upset with justin
for posting this picture i believe still
may be upset um
but so i really love when somebody can
yeah you know what they had this thing
done and
he's by the way he's got by the way he
didn't have to admit that no no i would
never have questioned it no usually you
can see that kind of thing i can anyway
i feel like right one of the few skills
i have i think the advancements in hair
restoration um have been major in our
lifetimes since like when we were kids i
i remember seeing adults who had had
that done when i was a kid and they
looked like the hair plugs were crazy
crazy yeah still is every once in a
while you see like an older
version of that i guess but if you pay i
guess the if you pay for if you invest
community money yeah community
i was watching singles the other day
which i've talked extensively about on
the show the camera chrome movie it's so
[ __ ] good you got to see i've never
seen it oh okay it's great but add it to
the list oh yeah jeremy piven makes an
appearance very memorable speaking of
hair restoration it's crazy he's like
george costanza which who he who yeah
portrayed yeah when he was on seinfeld
in the mid 1990s
like 94 maybe those episodes are on
with piven god said this he was bald
singles was 1990 he was
he's bald it's great and by the way
that's okay it's okay it's okay to be
bald yes and it's okay to do something
about the baldness if it bothers you
here's what's most okay if you do
something about it and you're honest
about it to it honesty yeah but yes very
impressive
i love that about him so right away i
was like oh this is something that
honest person yeah and he was honest
about cheating in college yeah my god
that's so i mean that's not an honest
thing to do i i it's funny to be honest
about cheating because
i know but see i think in his defense
he was dyslexic and people thought of
him as slow he wasn't properly um
diagnosed he wasn't diagnosed so so he
you know felt probably felt like he had
to yeah and and the fact that he's being
honest about it now kind of makes up for
and looking at it he's not um
he's aware of it as being something that
wasn't like that a great thing to do to
cheat um he's acknowledging it i think
yeah you're right that honestly goes
such a long way by the way
his dyslexia it's crazy that he had that
that he struggles with that and was able
to do the soup i know so effectively he
did that seamlessly that's not easy to
do that well and he did it so well you
did point that out to him and i thought
i think you're right that his dyslexia
may have even helped him on that show
absolutely it forced him to not read off
the teleprompter and really learn the
material
and he ended up having such a great
grasp of the material he really owned
that material at first he kept
mentioning things you had been in galaxy
quest and ed i thought he may have been
teasing you a little bit
but then i started to realize he really
likes you and i think he's a fan of
yours and then by the end he he was like
i i need you to be on my podcast so i
think he really does like that's so
funny i misinterpreted that i mean i oh
god i didn't both have to miss it chill
mikhail snarkiness because you watch so
much with the soup i think it's because
i have an image of him i had an image of
him as being uh just sarcastic right
because he's he's got that persona in
the soup which i watched a lot of and
and
um his work i mean everything so it's
hard to see when he's being genuine yeah
yeah that's funny he's like a
renaissance man he plays football
he's cool he's funny yeah yeah and i
like how he went after he had that gig
that paid
acting gig
he decided to quit and
go to grad school like you really cared
about getting better you know this is
going to sound like an insulting thing
to say but i would never have imagined i
don't mean it that way and i'll explain
why i would never have imagined that
joel mchale went to acting school and i
say that only because um
it's it's i think it's an ignorant thing
to say now that i
say it out loud because what he does on
that show just seems so effortless
but but it in fact i think it takes a
lot more skill to communicate community
yeah like
your eyebrows
i can't i gotta stop saying that maybe
that's why i never got into the show
because i don't like to say the word and
so it's hard for me to talk about oh did
you guys see community last night yes
yes would you flip forever what's the
other word that's hard for you uh
immunity immunity oh community immunity
oh yeah weird it's something about the
community immunity community uh uh
ambiguity that's so funny yeah immunity
immunity immunity i mean if i think
about it i can say it he just seems like
a very grateful person yeah very
appreciative of what he has and what
he's worked for and how and he
acknowledges how lucky he is to have
gotten that big break and community and
juxtaposed with
chevy chase who he's like legendarily
difficult to work with
every time i hear it it makes me sad
because he's brilliant and it sucks
knowing that someone who's that
brilliant and has brought some joy to
people
is such a [ __ ] he's coming at it
from like a joyless place yeah then i
think about some older actors i've
worked with who
who were just struggling with you had
pain and and
you don't know where you don't know
where
people come from but like in particular
i was thinking about michael parks who
with whom i did tusk and
michael for the first few days was you
know there were some difficulties
working with him and uh
and then we we one day we i just started
asking him about his life and he opened
up about
what he's gone through and and like
tragedy like real tragedies that he that
he storms that he weathered that like i
i don't know how you get through it's
true you never know what people are
going through physically emotionally
right so right now and we shouldn't i
know i'm judging i know but it but yeah
i i
the only reason it makes me sad is
because
chevy chase always seen he brought such
joy and mirth to my life that's so birth
so
think of somebody
who's like
promotionally currently and then you
think well they must be dealing with
something right
all right here's the letter all right
here's a letter
ross
ross for less ross is a cool name you
don't hear a lot of
old-fashioned names yeah ross i i like
that it's like uh
arthur
or like uh
henry henry yeah
shout out to our
little cousin nephew oh boy uh-oh uh-oh
i need some solid food
bonjour
a christian it doesn't say that it just
says bonjour justin and christian by the
way i didn't read the subject because
i'm starting to fade subject is would
you rather from down under nice bonjour
how do you say bonjour in an australian
accent i don't know but i bet you can do
it
you got like this mischievous look in
your eye when you really challenged me
bonjour
justine chris no i can't
believe i can't do it chloe and ross
here from france in england we are
currently traveling around australia and
have very much enjoyed listening to the
pod throughout the trip maybe their
enjoyment ends now
it's so nice you guys to share with us
those intimate aspects of your lives and
with such honesty and humbleness as well
keeping it light and making us laugh
along the way ah thanks ross thanks ross
and chloe
we have a few dilemmas which we hope you
guys could resolve for us
firstly since the podcast often flirts
with the spiritual or mystical we would
like to know if you would rather
know what happens when you die or know
when you're going to die oh we were just
talking about this weren't we no one
you're going to die that's a great
question
i would i would rather know what happens
yeah me too because if me too if i know
what happens and i don't know when it's
going to happen i would and the thing
that anything that happens is something
i'm excited about uh-huh we're not
excited about but presumably it's a good
thing is good
then i would live a more reckless
lifestyle i think on earth
whereas if i found out that the
afterlife was really miserable i would
live like a like a nun meet me too on
this on this earth or if if i knew it
was like a traditional judeo-christian
judeo-christian idea of the in after
where is there where there's like a bad
pla a dark place you know
uh how that's what i'm saying yeah you
would live i would live appropriately
yes that's a great question
also when if you know when you're going
to die i don't know if i'd want to know
that in general just because it would
yeah it would make me live
well actually if you knew you were going
to die let's say in a year you would
really exactly make the most of it i
would like to know you would but i would
prefer knowing the first one ah okay
great question on matters not so
spiritual or mystical with the back to
ross leonard ross and chloe would you
rather
that's funny that's funny pippit uh i i
love this guy
our mattress not so spiritual or
mystical or maybe he's the french one
and that's not so spiritual
please okay sorry uh would you rather
ejaculate ugh which
is such a gross word and it's so gross
hearing you say it it's gross as a verb
would you rather ejaculate snot or
sneeze sperm oh man
please don't say ejaculate again now i'm
thinking of ejaculating like sneezing
you know where it's like
ejaculate is not my mom's gonna love
this
or sneeze sperm i don't see what the um
well if you ejaculate well i'd rather
impregnate something that's when you
might have kids right that's the thing
like if i was if i were ever to
procreate i would rather not have to use
my nose
so i would pick
i would pick that one i guess
did you just picture me doing that yes
yes let's get off this one uh ross wow
to go from something so
uh metaphysical to
disgustingly physical uh well done ross
i would rather ejaculate or sneeze sperm
all right ejaculates not
oh boy
would you rather cry tears of pee or
burp screams whoa it's funny to picture
you
our friend gemma hates burps so much um
so it's made me more and we've been
spending time with her and her friend
james this summer so it's made me more
subconscious her husband james oh boy
oh i don't know if i can do this uh i
would rather
uh cry urine because
the urine it wouldn't
people wouldn't notice it for one thing
uh as long as it wasn't dangerous it
wouldn't it wouldn't stink or anything
well unless you have coffee or
uh yeah i would definitely do that i
wouldn't want every time i burped i'd
scream i would that'd be crazy i
wouldn't have any friends yeah people
would be really scared of me you don't
burp that often yeah i do i drink a lot
of cell phone picture and you screaming
seltzer water would kill me yeah yeah
i'd have to i'd have to change my
lifestyle i'd have to never eat anything
or drink anything that yielded
burps or you'd have to not um eat
asparagus before you watched an
emotional movie like brian's song or
something sure or up okay great
questions ross we love and then he says
back to ross we loved comment and
unsupervised and we are very much
looking forward to seeing lady at the
manor yes oh we
you know what's unsupervised it's an
animated show are you on that yeah on fx
thanks sorry um i think it only lasted a
season and you finally saw a comment a
very good very good movie yeah
very good performance by you thank you
and emmy ross yeah he's great it back to
the letter chloe would like to know if
you can do a french accent well no
i guess she just
she's already just heard my attempt
i don't no it depends on how much food
i've eaten how no i can't
cheers back the letter cheers chloe
and chloe's thing oh chloe's thing look
at the emoji they include emoji chloe
and ross like a little devil yeah she's
a little purple devil chloe's a little
purple devil and ross is upside down
smiling face um anyway that's a great
thank you what a great letter uh
and sorry for my low blood sugar i'm
apologizing to all the listeners to you
uh yeah it's okay i forgive you thank
you to joel mchale hilarious
yeah i can't wait to be friends honest
joel mchale
and everyone go listen to his podcast
yeah
the darkest timeline and watch old
episodes of community on netflix and uh
the movie becky which is streaming oh
and if you guys want to write in yes and
uh
give us some mood have you eaten in a
while i'm just starting to slow down uh
if you guys want to write in
and write us a letter and maybe a would
you rather or two our email address is
life is short at wondery.com
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
i've been your host justin
is hosted by me try again life is short
is attempted to be hosted by me justin
long and it's co-hosted and produced by
you christian long as well as megan
monaco senior producer is michelle
audio engineer is sergio enriquez
executive producers are marshall louie
and ernan lopez
for wondering okay
[Music]
remember the name okay yesterday
margaret we talked about
a player in the nba who was five foot
three who's very small
do you remember his name
murray burrow
[Laughter]
millie murray
bird bird bird
yeah close bugs
because i remember boogers remember when
you said huggy
yeah
you're on the right track a combined
huggy with that buggy
huggy bose yeah what's he pointing to
huggy cuppy
monkey bows
muggy's bows
monty bows
no you had the mug bugsy bugs yeah
monkey bugs well i hope he's the guest
on the show now we can play this
you